Bob/Muyskerm: Are you on an island?
Mark/Markiplier: Are you running towards me? Oh god.
Mark: Hello.
Bob: I am not currently running towards you!
Mark: Hello friend, hello sergent potato. How are you?
Bob: *laughing*
Mark: Alright, I'm gonna move on. Alright, goodbye new friend. I must go find other friend, you stay safe, out there.
Bob: Oh I'm wet.
Mark: Okay, so you did see the red tower though?
Bob: Well, maybe.
Mark: Oh, no there's- there could be a lot of red towers.
Bob: How the fuckin' shit do I get out of here?
Bob: I'm like drowning in the water right now.
Mark [exasperated]: I just- look, I found a sign!
Mark: Jesus, I can't read it. It's a sign that's just like an MS Paint drawing that says "You're an F-Word Harry!"
Bob: *laughs*
Mark: There's a dick jizzing out the right side!
Mark: I thought It was gonna be like a profound sign like
Mark: "No swimming in the water!"
Bob: *laughs*
Mark: Oops!
*jingling noises*
Mark: I hear jingle bells. Ooo jingle bells.
Bob: That's just my baells.
Mark [Slavic accent]: I got small and medium present. Unwrap, unwrap, unwrap...
Bob: Oh shit.
Mark: Ooh, I got a gun!
Bob: I think it's weird you have to unwrap 1 box like 6 times.
Mark: Yee. I've got a gun
Bob: I just wanna say that. "Loading river layout"? Neat.
Mark: How do I load? I don't even know if I have the right bullets.
Bob: That was sort of my downfall.
*CRACK*
Mark: Wup! Ok, that works.
Mark: Shit, I've announced my position.
*both laugh heartily*
Mark: Boom!
Bob: You ringing the dinner bell there?
Mark: Yeah, "Let the games begin!" Kepush!
Mark: Where are you at?
Bob: I am the- receiving the data.
Mark: Oh okay.
Bob: Yes! I am awake! It appears to be completely pitch dark out here.
Mark: It is indeed, it is dark.
Bob: Fucking awesome.
Mark: Turn on your torch, let me see if I see you.
Bob: Well my torch is on.
Mark: Well I see- I don't see anything. *giggle*
Bob: I'm at a house called Gene's base.
Mark: Niiice.
Mark: Do you see a lighthouse? That's the landmark that I see in the distance.
Bob: Not even at all.
Mark: You're not by a river?
Bob: Is it by a river or by a coast?
Mark: By a river.
Bob: Alright, I don't see a river yet.
Mark: Let me know if you see like a satelite dish.
Bob: Uh... no.
Mark: The moon is above...
Mark: That does not help anybody. But the moon is above.
Bob: The moon is right up there, yep.
Bob: Well I'm on top of a very large mountain, hill, sort of thing right now, at uh, what appears to be a quarry machine of some sort.
Mark: Cool. What do you see?
Bob: An automatic digger.
Bob: I don't see a lighthouse. So fuckin' foggy that I'm high enough up that I don't honestly see anything.
Bob [singing]: I was gonna clean my room, but then I got high.
Mark: Nice.
Bob [singing]: I was gonna do something else also, but then I got high.
Bob: But I- Don't do drugs kids.
Mark: Oh yeah, of course.
Bob: Well fuck. Alright, so I'm at an extremely wide section of river.
Mark: Ah, so you are near river then.
Bob: Yes, I'm gonna be near the river.
Mark: Your torch still on?
Bob: Yep, I'm on the bank right now, my torch on, it's VERY wide.
Mark: Ok, I'm-
Mark: No lighthouse in sight?
Bob: When you look at the lighthouse, the moon is like straight fuckin' up right now.
Mark: Yeah.
Bob: How are we supposed to fuckin' find anything? Is there a light like beaming from the lighthouse?
Mark: No, it's just a pillar.
Bob: Alright, okay, well, 'cause I see like a thing in the distance that's a big pillar lighthouse-esque sort of shape.
Mark: Uh huh. Does it have like- looks like it has glass at the top of it?
Bob: Uh no, it's all kind of dark. So I can't really tell.
Mark: Hmm...
Mark: Woah, what are you? Is that a DEER?!
Mark: I'm gonna shoot dat deer. Immuna get dat deer. Sneak up, I'm sneakin', sneakin' all over this deer.
Bob: Fuck on that deer.
*BANG*
Mark: Boam bitch! Nope, didn't do nothin' to the deer. Ok, that was a waste of a shell.
Bob: Yeah, I- This is definitely a lighthouse kind of thing, but I don't know if it's the same one you were seein'.
Mark: No?
Bob: Was yours kind of like on the water?
Mark: Yeah, it's in the middle of the water, on a little island.
Bob: Oh yeah, mine also is that thing.
Mark: Wait, are we looking at the same thing then?
Bob: I'm on the coast next to it. Down shore do you see like a little hut?
Mark: Well, I'm about to climb on to this thing, I'm-
Bob: On to the lighthouse?
Mark: Yeah, I'm going very slowly. I don't have my torch out right now, I'm in the water.
Bob: Are you swimming out to it?
Mark: Yeah.
Bob: I'm walking out here, also. I'm gonna try and climb up on this lighthouse structure thingy.
Mark: Oh no. I think- If you're already climbing on it, I don't think we're in the same place.
Bob: No? Well, but I- how? It's like a fucking castle.
Bob: How are you climbing on it?
Mark: I don't know, it MUST be different things that we're looking at.
Bob: Don't give up hope yet. Alright I found the door.
Mark: Yeah, so we must be in completely different places, so, how do we make a fuckin' bed?
Bob: Well, when you hit Tab, you can go into crafting.
Mark: Ah.
Bob: And in there, there are things such as common.
Mark: Such as the like as the Iraq.
Bob: Such as and like A BED!
Mark: Yeah, beadrolls! A SLEEPING bag. That's what I was looking for. Sleeping bag only needs 30 cloth.
Bob: Ohhh, is that a Tool?
Mark: Yeah- No! I just- There's a searching, I just searched for Bed.
Bob: I don't know how to do that.
Mark: It's at the bottom, it's towards the bottom of it, not quite the bottom.
Bob: Don't teach me, just do it for me.
Mark [softly]: Oh, okay, alright then, eh jeez eh.
Bob: OH! OH! GUNS!
Mark: Guns?
Bob: GUNS!!!
Mark: You hear guns, or you see guns? You found guns?
Bob: GUNS!
Mark: You found guns?
Bob: HEARING GUNS! Hearing guns.
Mark: Oh, oh that's not good.
Bob: I was just in my inventory and all of a sudden it was all...
Bob: "Baaang, bang bang."
Mark: *laughing*
Mark: Well at least the day- Sun's coming out, so that's nice.
Bob: So they can find me, hooray.
Mark: I'm going towards the shore.
Mark: I don't know how to make cloth.
Mark [high pitched]: How do I- how do you make cloth again?
Bob: Are you hearing the guns?
Mark: No, I'm not hearing the guns.
Bob: There's like a serious fucking gunfight going on.
Mark: Hmm, OH! There's! There's Hemp Plants that give you CLOTH!
Bob: What they look like?
Mark: I dunno, it was kind of like a little Christmas Tree on the ground.
Mark: It was in a field. They're about person-height. They're dark green. Uh, the leaves look like weed leaves.
Mark: And they give you cloth.
Bob: I might be doing a dumb thing right now, but I'm opening up some of these cans to try and get-
Mark: Nice.
Bob: *gasp* I got Crude Oil. OH! Do you hear an airdrop?
Mark: No...?
Bob: I see an airdrop!
Mark: Man, I hear nothing. OH I SEE IT! It's a- WAY in the distance for me.
Bob: Ok, it's like right over me right now almost.
Mark: Ok, so I know which direction you are, but I've made- I'm making a Sleeping Bag like right now.
Mark: And apparently, I can gift it to someone. Maybe stay away from that, that airdrop, by the way.
Bob: Yeah, well I don't think it actually dropped yet, did it? I didn't see it drop anything, I just see the plane.
Mark: Ok, so-
Bob: Is it over you yet?
Mark: No no, it's WAY still way in the distance.
Mark: Ok, so... If I know my things about this thing...
Bob: *chuckles* Which I'm sure you do.
Mark: What the fuck did I just do?
Bob: *laughs*
Mark: I right clicked it, and now it's gone!
Bob: *laughs loudly* Is it on your hotbar?
Mark: Oh yeah, no wait, it's fine.
Bob: *laughs*
Mark: I've got it, I've got it.
Bob: Dude, obviously right click is delete. Fuckin' idiot.
Mark: Apparently I can craft an accoustic guitar.
Bob: That seems like a thing you need.
Mark: Hmm, I can craft some pants, cover up my nudity.
Bob: Hopefully some of this fuckin' stuff I'm finding has food in it. C'mon.
Mark: I'm runnin' towards that place that you said you were over the...
Bob: Yeah, I'm running in the direction of the...
Bob: The th- the- the thing was flying,
Mark: Oh okay.
Bob: And if you need rope, got a fuckload of rope!
Mark: OH I SEE! I see the snow capped mountain!
Mark: It is- It is SO far away. *laughs*
Bob: I'm on top of that bitch right now.
Bob: Hooray!
Mark: It is- It is SO in the distance
Mark: Wow, that is far.
Bob: I just came over the top of the snow capped mountain!
Mark: Ok, good. Why did you go up to the top of that? *chuckle*
Bob: 'Cause that was the quickest way to go in the direction that you are.
Mark: Ok, alright, wow, this map is fuckin' big.
Bob: My rock is almost out of durability, what the fuck do I do when my rock's out of durability?
Mark: *laughs* Dude, I don't know man.
Mark [caveman]: WHAT WE DO WHEN ROCK BREAK?! I fuck don't know!
Mark: Ok, I'm almost at the base of the snowy mountain.
Bob: Woah really?
Mark: Yeah.
Bob: Me here too.
Mark: Okay, alright. Me walking towards mountain, see Power Line, you see power line?
Bob [softly]: Power line? No.
Mark: Oh, you must be on the other side of it.
Bob: I'm gonna come towards what I think is your side, but there might be wolves over here, so this might be really stupid.
Mark: Wolves?! Wait, okay, I'm now seeing another snow capped mountain.
Bob: Ah fuck, no. No! No! NO! NO!
Mark: Ok, this might be a snow cap hill, might be more of a hill, I see a bigger one that might be more mountain-esque
Mark: Ok, but do you see at all in the distance some power lines?
Bob: Uh, I see a very tall lighthouse that looks like it's glass on top!
Mark: Fucking WHAT?!
Bob: I'm not very close to it, hang on.
Mark: I think I know y- I think I'm still on the right hill, but I think...
Mark [whisper]: You don't see any power lines?
Bob: I don't, but I- My vision of the horizon is a little bit obscured right now.
Bob: I'm like about to come over a very small crest.
Mark: Uh huh.
Bob: I'm also still collecting hemp cloth and stuff while I'm on my way.
Mark: Nice.
Bob: I don't see any power lines.
Mark: Oh no.
Bob: I'm gonna continue going in this direction.
Mark: Oh no...
Bob: Did you just say "God you're hot," or is that just what I wish you had said?
Mark: *laughs*
Mark: I said "Oh no," but you can go with that one.
Bob [gruntingly]: God you're hot.
Mark [gruntingly]: Ah your tits are fucking amazing.
Mark: I've never said this to you before, but you have great tits man.
Bob: I appreciate that.
Mark: I don't know where you would be, but you SAW the lighthouse?
Bob: I'm circum- wait! Power lines! I see power lines!
Mark: Ooo! You do? *grunts* Big ones or small ones?
Bob: I'm getting such a boner right now because I see power lines.
Bob: Oh my god, very big!
Mark: Oh yeah! Do you see a broken one?
Bob [gruntingly]: Oh, maybe.
Mark: Alright, there's a broken one, that's what I'm next to right now, just follow those power lines baby!
Mark: Follow them AWAY from the sun, that's the way. No wait, maybe towards, I don't know which way you are from me.
Bob: They're sort of going along side this- Is this a missile silo? No, that's not a missile silo.
Mark: I'm right by the broken one.
Bob: If you're facing, if you're sort of facing the snowy mountain.
Mark: Yeah?
Bob: I'm going directly towards the big power line stuff from the snowy mountain.
Bob: I'm in like kind of an opening right now, where it's like, uh, orangey yellow grass, and lots of rocks.
Mark: *sucks through teeth* mm, mhm.
Bob: It's kind of a ravine.
Mark: I think I know where you are. Yeah, I'm headed right towards that direction.
Mark: I think we're about to make contact.
Bob: God, ah yeah.
Mark: I'm gonna turn off my censoring, just for this moment.
Bob: *laughs*
Mark: Turning it off. I can't wait.
Bob: Oh, god!
Mark: Oh fuck, I want it!
Bob: Alright, I'm right by power lines, I'm not by a broken one, but I'm getting very close to power lines.
Mark: Ok, oh I see a ravine with brown grass and rocks.
Mark: Unh fuck! Censoring's off, baby! Goin' in raw!
Bob: All I've got is shoes on, just for you baby.
Bob: Wait, so I see little ones and big ones.
Mark: Yeah, that's good, I'm by little and big.
Bob: I don't see broken, is it a broken little one or a broken big one?
Mark: Uh, it's a broken big one. God, I feel like we're so close!
Bob: Uh, they end at like a walled-in town area?
Mark: whaaat? OH NOOOOOO!
Bob: Is that the- Oh is that where you were?
Mark: No, no, I have no idea where that is!
Bob: WAIT! I see a broken- I see a big broken one!
Mark: Okay, is it a big broken one by a tree? Or is it a broken one by itself?
Bob: Uh, it's near some trees, but it's sort of mostly by itself.
Mark: Ok. Alright, are you near it?
Bob: I'm right under it. It's kind of by a weird base situation?
Mark: Oh no. We're- I feel like we're close.
both: We've gotta be, gotta be so close! C'mon!
Mark: C'mon, not us, customer service, not us.
Bob: *giggles*
Mark: I went around the area, I tried to find that walled-in town you were talking about, but I'm going back to the power lines.
Mark: It- The thing about these power lines is they're literally right next to a snow capped hemp hill mountain.
Bob: Yeah, that's, yeah, that's where I came from.
Mark: Do you hear this sound?
*child quietly says quack*
*GASP*
Mark: You heard that?!
Bob: Did you just shoot a gun?!
Mark: I shot a gun!
Bob: Oh fuck yes!
Mark: I'm right by the one with the trees.
Bob: MARK I'M COMING!
Mark: YOU'RE COMING?!!!
Bob: *orgasm noise*
Mark: *orgasm noise* Ohhh!
Bob: You were sort of over a hill from where I was.
Mark: Alright.
Bob: Along the power lines that run right by the woods.
Mark: Yeah, I'm gonna fire again-
Mark: Oh! I see you! I see you!
Bob: *gasp*
Mark: That better be you.
Bob: Where?!
Mark: Ok, wait, you did- stop moving, hang on.
Bob: Where? Where?
Mark: Ok, is that you? That you? Is that you? Is that you!
Bob: *ORGASPM* MARK!!! AHH!!! *giggles*
Mark: OH MY GOD! NICE TITS!
Mark: Jesus, I gotta turn on censoring, Jesus.
Bob: *laughs gleefully*
Mark: *laughs generously*
Bob: I gotta turn off censor and see what yours looks like.
Mark: Yes! See what I'm packin' baby!
Bob: Oh.
Mark: Let me stand on this rock for ya! Hang on. Yeah.
Bob: Man, that's- that's just rubbery and not...
Mark: I know right!
Mark: I like- Why are you bald? You're bald.
Bob: Why am I what?
Mark: You're bald. WAIT, that's why we all have no hair! The RADIATION EXPLODED IT off of us!
Bob: Ah, yours is growing back though.
Mark: Wait where?
Bob: Your- I can see like hair growing in spots on your head, like you just shaved.
Mark: Oh. Wait, you get close enough, I can still see the nipps peering through!
Mark: Oh my god, your tits are amazing! Oh yeah! Oh god yeah!
Bob: *balalah noise*
Bob: I don't wanna do that with you, nothing personal.
Mark: Oh, okay, that's fine, I understand.
Bob: It just doesn't have the same effect.
Mark: Ok.
Mark: BUT HEY! We found each other! ALRIGHT! 40 minutes in! Yeah! Woobie-doobie-doo!
Bob: *laughs*
Bob: Have any food? I'm dying.
Mark: No, I- I need water. I need like a lotta water.
Bob: So, how do I make a sleeping bag? *laughs*
Mark: Yeah, uh, you should have cloth.
Mark: I'm just gonna put it at like, right there.
Bob: I've got some. Alright I have enough. Boop.
Bob: Crafting a sleeping bag, so that when we inevitably die, we can come back to life with each other.
Mark: Oh! I just figured out how to give it to a friend.
Bob: God damn you! *laughs*
Mark: *laughs* I literally, if you hold Use down on it when you place it, it's "Give to a friend."
Bob: Ah God I can't believe we found each other!
Mark: Yeah, we finally did, jeez. OH! I'm crafting it right now, I forgot that it takes time to craft stuff.
Bob: Wait, so you have a bow and shit too?
Mark: Yeah baby, look! I got a bow.
Mark: I'm a provider.
Bob: I'm still- You have a bow, but the arrow is coming out between your pinky and ring finger.
Mark: Hey, don't ask questions. Hey, who has THE BOW?! And who DOESN'T have a bow?
Bob: *laughs*
Bob: Hey, you know what?
Mark: Yeah? Yeah what?
Bob: That's fine with me.
Mark: I'm gonna- I'm gonna- I'm gonna plant these hemp seeds and hopefully they'll grow into something later.
Bob: You DID provide a small amount.
Bob: *gasp* Is that what these are? Oh I've got LOTS of hemp seeds friend!
Mark: So yeah! I'm just planting a whole bunch over there. Maybe they'll grow, maybe they won't.
Bob: I'm just spam planting them over here. I don't know if they need water or what, but who fucking cares?
Mark: Yeah man.
Bob: We found each other. I was pretty sure we were never going to actually find each other.
Mark: Really? Aw man.
Bob: I- I had fears and doubts, man.
Mark: Man, you should always believe. Listen to this hopeful music, and just reach down deep in your heart and believe that you can be somebody someday.
Bob: The hopeful, desolate tones of the xylophone that's currently accompanying this extravaganza?
Mark: *chortles* You have a xylophone playing?
Mark: I have like a haunting melodic like piano, you don't have that?
Bob: No.
Mark: Ok, well, I DO, so just IMAGINE that!
Mark: Along with like the-
Bob: Ok, I'll imagine your music.
Bob: What do the rocks look like? My rock's almost dead. How do I get a rock?
Mark: Uhh, *huff* It's like... They look like the rocks on the ground, but they're not quite like all the other rocks on the ground.
Bob: Oh okay. Neat.
Mark: I don't know, man. It's just some rocks on the ground that you can pick up, you gotta look at rocks, man.
Bob: Oh sure, okay.
Mark: This is "RUST: The Look at Rocks Game," where you look at rocks!
Bob: I guess that is true, I do recall spending a lot of time walking around being like, "Can I collect this? Can I collect this?"
Mark: Yeah.
Mark: I remember smacking bears in the ass with rocks, before, that was a thing that happened.
Mark: No. Mine! Mine! MINE MINE! NO! MINE!
Bob: Mine.
Mark: MINE! No, too late! It's mine.
Mark: I'm gonna wump this barrel. You can have THAT barrel.
Bob: Oh my god that is SO LOUD
Mark: *laughs*
Bob: Earlier when people found me, it was because I had just done THIS and someone was like, "Oh, a dumbass to kill."
Mark: Alright so, what are we planning?
Mark: Did I-  I didn't even start the episode. Ok, there's a can of tuna and an apple here. Do you need food?
Bob: I'm actually starving. Are you starving?
Mark: I have some food, I had a candy cane. Ok, I'm gonna drop this apple, boink!
Bob: Candy cane? Sustenance!
Mark: Is that good? Is that good for ya, baby?
Bob: Uh, doesn't say I'm starving anymore!
Mark: I'm a provider!
Bob: I am still naked and everything, but, you know, you did what you said.
Mark: I'm a provider.
Bob: Also, is there any way for us to like, put a beacon on our lovely things on the floor, or if I get lost am I just boned forever?
Mark [squeakily]: Ehh, I don't know!
Mark: I don't know. To be honest, I don't think we need to worry about that, because if we die, we'll go back to it so, you know.
Bob: But we'll lose all of our valuable things I totally have.
Mark: Yeah man, I dunno what to tell ya.
Bob: *GASP* Is this a rock? This one looks different!
Bob: No, it's the same.
Mark: *laughs*
Bob: I kinda wish there was distinguishing features on this rock.
Mark: We gotta get out of this-
Mark: Oh, HI EVERYBODY! My name is Markiplier and this is Bob so...
Bob: Oh, right, uh huh, hello!
Mark: Also you should smack the trees and get wood. Did you get wood?
Bob: Oh, I thought you were gonna say "Smack that Like Button!" *laughs*
Mark: *laughs* You gotta SMASH that Like Button!
Bob: Can we get this video to TEN MILLION LIKES?!
Mark: A HUNDRED TRILLION LIKES, PLEASE!!!
Bob: I still don't have anything to smack the tree with.
Mark: Yeah...
Bob: Can't fist it. You used to be able to fist 'em. Now you can't fist 'em anymore.
Mark: Oh man...
Bob: Oh, that's not how I like it, that's not cool.
Mark: I've got a machete. I found a machete, dude.
Bob: Ah, I saw another person and my instinct was just like "Ah no! Run!"
Mark: Was it me?
Bob: It's still you.
Mark: Is it still me?
Bob: Yeah.
Mark: I just like how you're running in the distance and I just see a little pixelated blur
Bob: Wouldn't want any of those BOOBS to flop out!
Mark: Oo! A CAVE! Dude, come up here! Come up on the hill where I was. There's a cave!
Bob: I'm a-comin'.
Mark: This can be OUR CAVE!
Bob: Right back where you just were?
Mark: Dude! This can be our CAVE!
Bob: Our cave where I can starve to death, over and over.
Mark: Oh my god.
Bob: Oh hey, there it is, found it, I see you.
Mark: You found it? You see me?
Bob: I'm coming from your right. Hullo!
Mark: Where are you?
Mark: Oh THERE you are! Ok.
Bob: Hello!
Mark: Come in my cave!
Bob: Oh I'm in your cave.
Mark: Oh get in my cave.
Bob: Hey, is THIS a rock?
Mark: That's what I tried, and I smashed my machete and damaged it.
Bob: Is this a rocks? Nope, none of these are rocks.
Mark: Nope, it's all fake.
Bob: Any you guys got rocks?
Mark: Anybody got rocks?
Bob: I guess this is just dirt, these aren't rocks.
Mark: Anybody seen rocks?
Bob: Stupid, doesn't know what rocks look like.
Mark: *grunt laugh* Sorry.
Mark: Oh jeez, this is scary. This reminds me of The Forest.
Bob: This is a pretty sick cave. I feel like some sort of horrible creature lives down here.
Mark: Yeah, probably. You remember The Forest? The horrible caves?
Mark: Oh my god, that's a drop that we won't come back from!
Bob: Oh my god, it's dark over here!
Bob: Wait, WHERE'D YOU GO?!
Mark: Over here!
Bob: Oh hey! Oh my god!
Mark: Alright, ummm...
Mark: We're probably gonna die if we go down here, but I say we go down here.
Bob: Yeah, fuck it, why not?
Mark: Bibbity boop! Boobity boop. Boopity boop. Ohhh!
Bob: Oh my god, you're a badass! Just jumping down there, I can see why I picked you.
Mark: Thanks man, yeah, alright- WOAH!
Bob: I just hear big swingin' junk.
Mark: Hey, yeah, this is pretty big, and it swings pretty hard.
Bob: The funny thing is it swings 0%! *laughs*
Mark: Hey, come on man.
Bob: When you move around It's just like, "Merp"
Mark: *laughs*
Mark: It's just like, filled with sediment.
Bob: Is this a *sigh* Wind Waker puzzles?
Mark [Dan's dad]: Don't fuck up! You did it!
Bob: I won't, I got skills.
Mark [Dan's dad]: You DID it! Do you pay bills with those skills?
Bob: What the-?  How? What? What IS this CAVE?
Mark: Oh! Did you see that?
Bob: Oh, ok, the light?
Mark: *giggles* The "Loading" light.
Bob: You going left or right?
Mark: Uh, I'm gonna go right, left seems like death.
Bob: There's some light over here- nah, it's just reflections of nothing.
Mark: Woah, what happened here?
Bob: Is there lore to this game now?
Mark: Dude, I don't know- WHAT IS THIS?!
Bob: The underground community that died because it dug too deeply and...
Mark: The fuck? It's a LIFT?!
Bob: *GASP!!!*
Mark: Uhh, you first!
Bob: Oh! Wait! Come back!
Mark: Ya gotta get IN it! FUCK! Oh no!
Bob: *laughs*
Mark: Oh, why didn't we think of that? You have to be IN it! *laughs*.
Bob: Maybe it'll come back. Maybe it goes UP and DOWN.
Mark: Uh, something tells me that's NOT how this works. Oh no.
Bob: It'll come back.
Mark: It'll come. It'll come back. OH IT'S COMING BACK!
Bob: HA! I told ya! I knew! I knew!
Bob: Wait, so now let's explore the other pathway now that we know there's a lift of some sort.
Mark: Yeah, alright. Yeah.
Bob: Dude, we're gonna take that up, and come out and be like, "Man I wonder where our sleeping bags was at."
Mark: We don't need to go back for the sleeping bags.
Bob: "I wonder-" No wait! Mark! Oh that is the way.
Mark: Yeah.
Bob: I know, but when we die, we'll go back to them and then this will all be meaningless.
Mark: Yeah, exactly.
Bob: These tunnels literally were just dug by a huge fucking worm.
Mark: Probably.
Bob: Also is this just the SAME as the other room?
Mark: Yeah, it's another lift.
Bob: So you wanna get in and see what happens?
Mark: Try to get in with me, stand on my head.
Mark: Ok, this is a GREAT VIEW! For ME!
Bob: This is fine.
Mark: Oh god yeah. Nope! Oh bye! Thanks for leaving me!
Bob: Oh, oh! Oh god
Bob: Um, it says "0% Stable" on the lift right now.
Mark [squeakily]: Yeah, that's fine.
Bob: Should I ride it back down or should I-
Mark: Nah nah nah, you stay up there, it'll come back down, I'll come join you in a second.
Bob: What if I just break it and it doesn't come back down?
Mark: Please- ! There's another lift, so I think I'll be okay.
Bob: Just give it the old *thrust grunt*, alright.
Mark: Just give it the old *thrust grunt*, slam my crotch against it a few times.
Bob: Interesting point. We're not actually out of the cave up here. We're just in another cave.
Mark: Oh, really? Well that's not good.
Bob: *laughs*
Bob: There's no way- There's not even any LIGHT up here! It's just pitch blackness.
Mark: Jeez, maybe we shouldn't have done this, huh?
Bob: *laughs*
Mark: Maybe this was just a bad-
Bob: I mean, I don't have anything super valuable, I don't know.
Mark: Yeah, I mean, it's not like we were actually trying to build a base or survive or anything.
Bob: It's not like we had a chance anyways, like whatever, fuck it.
Mark: Hello, Bobbi Boi. Woah! Woah I'm stuck!
Bob: Woahoah! You're coming out the bottom!
Bob: *laughs forever*
Mark: Fuck- wa!!!!! NO! I'm- Oh fucking FUCK!
Bob: *sustained laughter*
Mark: I'm wounded! Come get me! I've been wounded. *laughs*
Mark: Oh god, my screen is freaking the fuck out!
Bob: Oh my god, I can hear you screaming in the distance!
Mark: *hearty laugh*
Bob: Are you just a psychopath who's just like "Ahhhh!"?
Bob: Can you get back in the thing or what?
Mark: No, I can't move! It says "You will die unless you get help soon."
Mark: YOU DIDN'T RIDE IT BACK DOWN?!!?!?!?!?!?
Bob: ... No, I was busy laughing!
Mark: WHAAT?!! Why didn't you help me?!?!!
Mark: I'm gonna die-
Bob: When you said- Oh, welp, hey!
*CRUNCH*
Mark: Ohh h h fuck dude! Oh no...
Bob: *escalating laughter*
Bob: Now we're just screaming at each other!
Mark: Jesus man. Well, I mean, I'm DEAD. I'm literally.
Bob: Like helpless morons in a pit. We're just like "DAhhh! Arrghlh!"
Mark: *laughs*
Mark: This is like "Ah! I broke my leg! Jump down and help me!" Krrk! "AH! MY LEG!"
Mark: I'm gonna- I'm dead, so I'm gonna spawn in my sleeping bag.
Bob: I'm spawning at Babsack. Hey buddy!
Mark: Oh heyyyy. It's like NOTHING happened! Oh, the hemp is growing! Do you SEE that?
Bob: *GASP*
["Crazy La Paint" by MiniMusicMan plays sustained]
Mark: So thank you everybody so much for watching! We fucked up real bad! But that's okay. 'Cause I didn't even do an intro, so-
Mark [softly]: but that's ok, you can forgive us, right guys? *sigh* oh man...
Bob: *laughs*
Mark: So thank you everybody, so much for watching, and, as always, we will see YOU, in the next video, BUH BYE!
Bob [softly]: Bye...
[Music intensifies]